knight f6 okay let's try bishop g5 this
time
i think it's called trompowsky opening
there is also a funny joke that
uh magnus played it in the first game of
the world championship
match against caracan because trump
became a president so he probably wanted
to praise trump
this way playing trompowsky opening
okay knight e4 is the main move i
believe
let's go bishop h4 i think it's
considered to be really bad because of
like g5 or something
but as far as i know people started
trying it again
like this g5 f3 gtx h4 ftx e4 c5 was
considered
was considered to be just bad for white
but i think they kind of started trying
it again
i don't know if you three is a move
though yeah bishop h6 so why would they
why would they like it i don't know
well do we do we protect e3 or we just
start
doing some crazy things like queen h5
bishop c4
yeah it's hard to say was better
okay let's try to play something really
stupid like queen h5
and bishop c4
i mean at least we're threatening
checkmate
at least we managed to get this far
yeah e6 and then i thought we'd just go
knight c3
which once again is probably it's
probably bad for white
but this kind of makes sense it's not
exactly idiotic
c takes d4 we go knight b5 then we go
knight f3
we kind of managed to develop the pieces
and yeah
then we'll have ideas i believe
he goes h6 preventing knight b5
which makes sense
but now it's really tricky like we can
go queen
queen five runs into bishop to xd4
so what i wanted is a queen e5 followed
by knight d5
maybe we'll get it later like he plays
ctxd for now
for instance and then we can play queen
e5
attacking a shade
and he has to do something
yeah he castles that's why i probably
i mean maybe i should have played
something like 95 instead
but even this is not that simple okay we
just i think we just retreat
he will probably play knight c6 i
believe
there is nothing wrong with that yeah
and we go queen h5
now it feels like it kind of makes sense
to play queen a5 checks to trade queens
here
because otherwise i think we'll just
take on a three castle
and then we try to create some sort of
an attack
maybe this will never happen actually
but
still i feel like it's uh
it's promising so this is a really
strange move okay i guess we take
now we cancel either way i don't know
what's here because so long
and we start collecting
collecting stuff so let's say we take
let me take here
so now knight f5 is also a threat
he has to be precise like queen g7 maybe
but even there it's obviously very very
comfortable for white
he goes queen f7 which is also legal
so yeah we probably just go back
for now
95 so we can play knight f5 here
we can also sort of ignore his play and
go bishop b3 i kind of like knight f5
though
yeah then we bring the knight to d6
which i think is an improvement
and then we just play like queen takes
c3
or maybe even king b1 to
to prevent a queen trait
yeah i think one kind of looks normal
and b should be stream
rook b so he's trying to to create some
kind of an attack
the queen side which i expect to fail
but who knows okay let's take he'll
probably go e5
now he goes we should be seven this is
logical
so we should probably start attacking um
f6
somehow like rook d2
yeah so here we probably just play like
a3
or maybe a3
yeah he goes before maybe i'm getting
outplayed but i'm
i'm not sure to be honest
like it's not exactly an attack he's
doing something but then we just go
before
and what do you want exactly i mean
it says bishop on c6 sort of prevents
him from
doing something good so that's why
okay let's go g4
i think we are fine with the queen trade
in general
so now the the plan is to
[Music]
is to run the pawns
okay collect one when you get a chance
okay take stakes now it should be just
lost for him
and this is checkmate i believe yeah
okay this was sort of tense once again
it was far from uh
from a brilliant level from us but
the the position was not that easy to
play msc